we kind of touched a little bit on kind
of brain function and mood and
concentration and things I wonder if you
could just sort of you know if someone
was was being like okay Sophie how do I
how do I change my diet such that it
improves my brain function or makes me
happy improves my mood what are like the
top recommendations here yeah great
question so
um Omega-3s are super super important
for our brain structure as we've talked
about and they can also help to protect
us from excess inflammation in the brain
which is linked to anxiety and
depression and stuff like that so either
make sure you're having at least two
portions of oily fish a week or take
care Omega-3 supplements B vitamins are
incredibly important for our brain
health they they produce they make
things like serotonin melatonin all of
our they make dopamine Gaba all of these
really important brain chemicals that we
really need all the time so B vitamins
are really essential for brain function
and we've got some really interesting
work showing that you can use B vitamins
in controlled circumstances in
replacement of ssris so anxiety and
depression treatments and they work in a
very similar way in the right doses at
the right moment for the right people so
B vitamin is super super important for
General brain function and brain health
and then we also think about things like
antioxidants and particularly the the
sign-ins from blueberries are amazing
for our brain health so not just
blueberries but anthocyanins come in
like red cabbage other dark purple
vegetables and there's some amazing data
showing that if children are given a
blueberry smoothie before an exam they
perform better in that exam than the
children who haven't had a blueberry
smoothie and then when we swap them over
and the level of the exam stays the same
and the first children are given the
blueberry smoothie not going to be with
me second to an R the children who had
the blueberry smoothie always perform
better than the children who didn't have
the Booboo smoothie so what we think is
happening there is it's getting better
blood to your brain and that is meaning
that you can have a better mental
performance in a very like short like
period of time so it's having that
direct impact on your brain health in
that moment and so with the smart
probiotic smart supplement we've got B
vitamins we've got other things like
iodine that are missing from people's
diets that have a big impact but we've
also got vitamin D which you really need
for your brain health as well I should
have mentioned that but we've got Amigas
B vitamins and anthocyanins as kind of
the core components with the other
essential things around it and I mean I
designed this right and then you you do
all the research and you put something
together and you think you know I think
that's going to work really well given
the research that we've got but you
always always have this kind of slight
skepticism and then when the reviews
started coming in for it I was like oh
my God it's really working for people
and it really works for me as well I
think with my ADHD and stuff those
nutrients are so important to me and it
really helps in terms of brain function
for lots of people and
the reviews really kind of speak for
themselves on that
can we zoom into Vitamin D what's going
on with the Trinity sure everyone just
so everyone knows everyone should be
taking vitamin D in the winter months in
the Western Hemisphere Northern
Hemisphere sorry because we just don't
get enough sunlight so the darker your
skin the less able you are to synthesize
enough vitamin D from the sunlight so
the way that those studies are conducted
are that people of all different skin
colors are put in the Spanish sunshine
in the summer for an hour lunchtime and
they see who how much vitamin D is
increased and they can see that the
darker your skin the longer you need to
be in the sun to synthesize the same
amount of vitamin D and the light of
your skin the less amount of time you
need to be in the sun to synthesize
vitamin D I'm a ginger I synthesize more
of Imaging than anyone else in the world
uh superpowers so vitamin D is really
really important for loads of different
things we think of it more as being like
a hormone now rather than a vitamin so
we see it within that capacity and it
helps to protect us from cancer it helps
protect us from it you know it's really
important for our immune function it's
really important for our brain health
vitamin D is a really really essential
nutrient for all of us and it speaks to
how our society has changed now that we
work indoors and we stay indoors all day
that you know such a huge percentage of
the population are vitamin D deficient
especially at this time of year so
Vitamin D supplements are super super
important I take them all year round I
think everyone out should too but it's
the government recommendations are that
everyone takes them between October and
April hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye